what's up guys st. clown posse is making
their way in what's going on man good to
see you good to see you yeah it's good
to see you guys yeah we were very bumble
you think we get to talk to you guys I'm
like I love these guys so we appreciate
you guys coming in you just you just
talking to McLemore outside you guys
know him or is this the first man that
was the first time we don't know any
stars like that are you done with the
celebrity and rap beef days no I mean is
it weird you will you meet people who
like you might not have been inclined to
like before and they know you and like
your stuff is this isn't immediately
like it's harder to hate them once they
like oh I'm a fan or personally you
can't really listen to their music and
dig it because you don't like that all
right you know what saying but you
sometimes it goes the other way you know
Macklemore is cool we said hi
that's all we did he didn't say none of
our liking us but I'll tell you this
usually if somebody does say that
they're usually the kind of person we
are anyway you know what I mean so we
usually already like them you know right
means so we don't usually get that you
know like we're now I can't think of any
circumstances that some of you said they
like our music and we've been surprised
by that can you know are you always
shocked if somebody likes me you don't
you try to play cool I go thank you but
then you're like a [ __ ] person knows
it's bizarre bizarre thing but you guys
have that you could take the makeup off
and kind of live in peace right a lot of
times without so so the fans will
recognize you yeah I mean you still get
it here and there you know saying but
I'm sure not as bad as Macklemore does
trying to walk down the street you know
yeah I just know that was him like
that's Macklemore in the blue jacket
he's also walking around in a bright
turquoise jacket are you guys surprised
at like the culture that you've created
and how people respond to it now cuz
it's almost like I mean I I feel like it
went through several phases of
acceptance and and and different ways
that the mainstream was taking it but
now I feel like it's a very unique time
because like for instance we had Taylor
Schilling in here
from orange is the new black yeah and
she's working on am you I mean you guys
must know she's working on a movie yeah
we were you guys were involved in and I
mean she came in and I just kind of
started talking to her about it just to
see if it was like one of those movies
where obviously this is based on
Juggalos but we're not mentioning
anything about the ICP as opposed to no
we're actually getting into it and she
knew everything yes your actual event
this year right yes she gathering yeah
yeah a movie again gather white tents
everywhere they had uh you know the
Ferris rides I mean the amusement rides
they had thousands the people it was
insane it looked just like the gathering
all recreated yeah yeah I mean it was
the gathering though it was going to be
crazy for something you guys like just
kind of put together cuz you're like
well if we're not gonna be accepted
we're just created ourselves we're just
put together like that so we just whip
together but to answer your question um
is it surprising yeah every day of my
life I can speak for me
very single day because we don't start
when we first started back you know
saying late 80s early 90s we didn't we
didn't intend for this to happen we just
wanted to be rappers that was it you
know saying so yeah I mean every day you
wake up you're like what though like how
are we so Luck's crazy and how are we so
um like it's also a seat feels like an
enormous amount of responsibility when
people are saying your music saved my
life you know like being a juggle will
save my life and they mean it it's
overwhelming how do you guys I'm sorry
have you changed it all because you look
you look like healthier you lost a lot
of weight and as you guys are so
successful you got money you everything
is great does it become harder to kind
of have like an aggressive or angry that
don't you find the commonality change
because I mean when you young in your
career you got anger and [ __ ]
you know you know that's going your way
you know there's a lot of anger that we
feel in today's anger is um it's hard to
be as angry when we've been showered by
love for the last 20 years the way we
have I mean love like immense amounts of
love Juggalos love you and Ryan to have
that sort of warmth around you every
night is hard to be as bitter about life
you know for us but looking at things on
a bigger picture not using our own
stories and using the stories of life
and others and using that anger you can
tap into it easily so you can tap into
anger about things that are happening to
other people or the things that are in
the world that have nothing to do with
your that's why yeah and as you know
having success is great but nobody can
escape no matter how much success nobody
can escape the trials and tribulations
of being human of having emotions having
anger depression you know everything
every kind of emotion like we all go
through it you can your problems change
you might not have trouble paying the
bills but you have trouble paying bigger
bills you have trouble paying right you
know every sort of these emotions
there's no escaping these emotions
you're gonna have them no matter what
you're doing what sparked you to lose
the way did you have a moment of clarity
where you're like man I just want to
look good why I did I did it was my knee
snaps my meniscus and I got it
surgically fixed and it snapped again
you know and there's no way to fix it
until I lost weight so I started trying
to lose the weight and then once I
started eating different I said but take
the whole concept of food the whole
concept of it and that's a pretty big
concept and delete it you know and I
took me forever but I think I was able
to successfully at this stage delete the
whole idea of food you know instead of
like thinking about like when people are
on a diet they think about what they're
gonna eat all day and they think about
what they're gonna have you know and
just take the whole concept of eating
and just pitch it you know you look
great too by the way thank you I got
sick and tired of women only [ __ ] me
for money I'm like once in a while they
have to enjoy it like I had to do
something cuz I just couldn't take that
look anymore
that like you know so what are you doing
like just I mean you can't not eat no I
wish I had something heroic to say I
don't I don't never worked out it's up
for concerts you know I I don't didn't
do [ __ ] I stopped eating
I still eat [ __ ] I just eat very small
amounts you know if you're if you want
to diet and starve yourself when you do
eat your stomach smaller from being so
hungry so you filled up real quick
just don't keep stuffing food on your
face like I used to just stop and just
barely enough to get by why are people
so scared we have to wrap shortly we
appreciate having you guys at all why do
people so scared of your fans like I've
done the gathering twice and they could
be aggressive and they yell a little bit
but they're nice they were all friendly
I didn't feel any shitty vibes from
anybody there was no physical aggression
threats walking among them why did they
have this people afraid of them man
it's insane if we knew man it's it's a
um what's happening to us has never
happened to any any group in music
history rock and roll history never I
mean it's one thing to make fun of a
band that's cool we understand it we get
it we know why we're made fun of we're
different we got clumping on crime but
to technically make it arguable that
it's against the law to be a Juggalo
because for the Juggalos for the FBI in
2011 to put Juggalos on the gang list
the top ten gang assessment list the
only year this list ever came out was
2011 and to say juggles our gang with
the Crips the Bloods ms-13 Aryan Nation
all that [ __ ] and label Juggalos on
there with them top ten and make it
official like that
yeah and now there's penalties to being
a gang member in this country if you get
popped for a bag of weed you're getting
a stiffer sentence if you're a gang
member so if you in the eyes of the
government you have a hatchet man
tattooed on you that's right all of a
sudden there's a gang and it goes all
the way up from a bag of weed to a
custody battle you know your spouse is
fighting you for custody of your
children in her or his attorney is able
to say Your Honor this is a gang member
in the eyes of the law and it's true
it's on a database and it's true because
you're a [ __ ] Juggalo do you think
that the FBI in a way was being
politically correct trying to say okay
well this is a white gang we can say
because we have
thirteen or we have the crimps we have
the Bloods we don't want to seem like
we're only targeting one group maybe
these fatty and Brotherhood is also oh
yeah oh yeah those guys are not exactly
otherwise okay there's a theory mostly
so it could there's a lot of them it's
because you guys kind of date what they
see is control a lot of people through
the music and like it's got to be a gang
there's certain things are getting paid
saying they have a gang from the
government so I combat their gang
problem you don't say these little like
suburban kids running around they get
more funding to these people loitering
and stuff you know saying there's six
Juggalos at a park having a barbecue
maybe four of them got misdemeanor
charges on their record and they're all
wearing the same thing and they're all
rocking this logo it's easy for the
police to make the argument that that's
a gang they know it's not a gang but
when it comes to getting that government
funding it's suddenly you know officials
telling troublemakers you know so yes a
gang they get money I don't even know if
the police cashing in on this gang thing
understood exactly what would become of
this because those seeds that were
planted in 2011 with that gang list have
grown since then and now it's insane
there was a woman who was a probation
officer for 15 years and on her walking
papers it said you're being let go
because we found out on your facebook
you're a Juggalo this is really shocking
sure of her wearing paint the clown
paint on her facebook and she was
fighting you know nothing wrong with her
work performance but they now classify
her as a gang member a gang member has a
probation of he's not very easy for the
Insane Clown Posse there's always
something people make it hard for ICP we
get it but the people I mean we've sold
8 million records right you're gonna
punish them now don't [ __ ] with the fans
right I mean that's insane I mean like
if they get it you don't you're not a
juggle you know like guys to be fine
cool we get it but really is it cool
that they do this to us who's next
what if it's the listeners of this show
right you don't say like what is next
and who's who to say this is not right
like how you can take our whole legacy
everything we built all the years we've
been doing this all the things our
people are proud of us for and then
staple a negative on it it's too bad
this is here whether it's a shame this
is here are you guys we have to we have
to wrap Athena's that's their say
you have other press to do we would talk
to you guys for an hour are you guys
promoting are you getting some kind of a
walk or what do you guys know March so
we want to promote that properly the
news Saturday with the National Mall in
DC yes yes okay what time the people
have to be the school clock is when it
starts two o'clock that's gonna be an
amazing event I wish I was in DC I would
love to go to that yeah we support it no
Juggalos here we suppose I'll tell you
this so I know it sounds preposterous
but yes what we're saying is true it's
real [ __ ] right it's hard to believe
it's we've been a lot of beefs in our
career and they're fun this isn't fun I
don't know how this is gonna end this is
a necessary thing to try to make a
statement about who your fans are and
who they're not and that's why we
appreciate you brother letting us be on
the show letting everybody hear our
argument right here this is the point of
the March we want to let the people of
this nation know we're not okay with it
we know the government can't stand them
say hey we just want to clarify they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah don't they were
wrong exactly they look like they're
even admitting that right so they're not
gonna do [ __ ] or say [ __ ] you know but
as long as the people of the nation know
we're not okay with it and it takes more
than the band it takes the actual people
the juggles to march that's why we're
doing it it looks like a publicity stunt
sure we get that but it is a publicity
stunt to generate publicity for what the
[ __ ] is happening to us man this is
right even if you're not an ICP fan this
is legit that the fans of a group can be
targeted just for gathering and getting
together and I've been to these
gatherings I've never seen anything
other than people just drinking and
having a good time and yelling never an
issue and as I've been on stage I've
never felt menaced once by anybody there
so go and support this just because if
it's if it's not these guys it's gonna
be a band that you like and that you
support and it's always nice to call
they're the jugglers a gang is it's
simply [ __ ] ludicrous so we love you
guys man thank you very please